we are told that researchers suspect
that myopia or nearsightedness is
becoming more common over time
a study from the year 2000 showed 132
cases of myopia in 400 randomly selected
people
a separate study from 2015 showed 228
cases in 600 randomly selected people
so what we're going to do in this video
is do a hypothesis test to see if we
have evidence to suggest
the researcher's suspicion that myopia
is becoming more common over time if at
any point you are inspired i encourage
you to pause the video and try to work
through things on your own but here i go
i'm going to do it with you
so let's just start off by setting our
null and alternative hypothesis
so remember our null hypothesis this
would be that the no news here so that
would be that
contrary to their suspicions that myopia
is not becoming more common over time
and so the way that we're measuring more
common over time is we could look at the
proportion of folks who have myopia in
2015 and compare that to the proportion
in 2000. so our null hypothesis is that
there's no difference is that the true
proportion of folks who have myopia in
2015
is equal to the proportion of folks who
have myopia in 2000
and then our alternative hypothesis
remember they are they suspect it's
becoming more common over time so that
would be a situation where our true
proportion in 2015 is greater than the
true proportion in 2000. in this
scenario myopia would be becoming more
common over time because 2015 happens
after 2000.
so before we even go about testing our
null hypothesis seeing if we can reject
it or not which would suggest our
alternative you have to look at your
conditions for inference and we've done
this many times before
you have your random condition and it
looks like we meet that because in both
of the samples we have 400 randomly
selected people randomly selected people
so that looks good then you have your
normal condition
and to meet your normal condition your
number of successes and failures in each
of the samples have to be at least 10.
and we see that that is the case we have
132 successes so to speak not that it's
a success for someone to have myopia but
the way this has been constructed that
would be a success and then 400 minus
132 failures in each case either of
those numbers would be greater than 10
and same thing for the sample from 2015.
so we're meeting both of those
and then the last condition that we
always talk about is the independence
condition
and two ways to get there
either you are sampling with replacement
or you feel good that your sample size
is no more than 10 of the population and
i think it is safe to say that even this
larger sample of 600 that there's more
than 6 000 people out there and so
i think it's reasonable to say that
we're meeting that independence
condition even though they're not making
it explicit here but it's good to always
think about this now the next thing you
want to do in a hypothesis test is set
your significance level
your alpha and i'll set my significance
level to 0.05
so we're now going to assume the null
hypothesis and say well what is the
probability of getting a difference
between 2015 and 2000 that is at least
as large as the one that we got and if
that probability is
less than our significance level then we
would reject our null hypothesis and
that would suggest the alternative if
that probability is greater than our
significance level then we fail to
reject the null hypothesis and we fail
to have evidence for the researcher's
suspicion
so let's move ahead with that so what we
want to do is let's come up with a z
value or a z-score
so our z
is going to be equal to the sample
proportion in 2015
minus our sample proportion in 2000
all of that over the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution of the
difference between the sample
proportions
in
2015
and 2000.
now this is going to be and i will say
approximately equal to we can calculate
this numerator exactly but this
denominator we are going to estimate
so this numerator is going to be let's
see in 2015 i'll use some different
colors 2015
we have 228 cases out of 600 so it's 228
out of 600 and then in 2000 we have 132
cases out of 400. so minus
132
over 400
and then all of that over
the square root
and what we use in the denominator here
under the radical sign is we use the
combined proportion
and we could write that as p hat sub c
and the reason why we use the combined
proportion we've talked about this in
previous videos is remember when we do a
hypothesis test we assume that our null
hypothesis is true and if our null
hypothesis is true there's no difference
between the proportions in 2015 and 2000
and so to get a better estimate of the
true proportion well we could we should
just add up our samples so our sample
size would be 600 plus 400
600
plus 400 and the number of cases of
myopia would be
228 plus 132
plus 132 which would get us to what is
this
360 over
1000 which is equal to 0.36
and there and we can use that inside the
expression when we're trying to estimate
our standard deviation of this sampling
distribution so this is going to be
0.36 times 1 minus 0.36 which would be
0.64
over the sample size in 2015 which is
600
plus
0.36 times 0.64
over the sample size in 2000 which is
equal to 400
and let's see before i even get my
calculator out i think i can simplify
this a little bit
228 over 600 228 divided by 6 is going
to be equal to 38 so this would be
0.38 let's see 132 divided by 4 would be
33 so this would be
0.33 and so our entire numerator is
going to be
0.05 so
0.05 and so now i could put this into my
calculator and i will get 0.05
divided by
the square root
of
let's see i'm going to have 0.36
times 0.64
divided by
600
plus
.36
times
.64
divided by
400
is going to get me
approximately 1.61
so this is going to be approximately
1.61
and so one way to think about it is the
difference that we got between our
sample proportions between 2015 and 2000
of 0.05 that that is 1.61
standard deviations above our mean of
our sampling distribution if we assume
that the null hypothesis is true
and so from this we can calculate our
p-value remember our p-value
our p-value is equal to the probability
that our z-score is at least that big is
greater than or equal to 1.61
and one way to think about it if we look
at the sampling distribution
or really we could just look at any
normal distribution now since we have
normalized for z
so we're looking at 1.61 standard
deviations above the mean
so z is equal to 1.61 so we're thinking
about this area right over here that
would be our p-value and to help us with
that we can get out a z table
and we see
this z table gives us the cumulative
area up to
some z score and so we would just have
to whatever this gives us we would just
have to do 1 minus that so if we go to
1.61 we get
0.9463 so it'd be 1 minus
0.9463
is equal to 1 minus 0.9463
which is equal to let's see it's
0.53 0.0537
0.0537
and notice this p-value is
ever so slightly higher than our
significance level but this is why we
want to set our significance level ahead
of time we don't want to get tempted to
say oh i'm so close let me just raise my
significance level a little bit more so
that i can reject my null hypothesis and
then i can have something that i can
tell my friends about no that would not
be good science that would not be good
statistics we have to be disciplined so
here because our p-value
our p-value
is greater than our significance level
even though it's varies by a very small
amount we fail
fail to
reject
our null hypothesis and another way to
think about it in terms of the context
of the question
we can say
that there is not
enough
evidence
to suggest
that myopia becoming more common over
time
myopia
becoming
more common
over time
and we're done